it's very easy and convenient to just
blame whoever is in charge when
something bad happens but it's not
always accurate for example gas prices
it's very popular to blame a president
particularly one you don't like when gas
prices explode
the reality is presidents only have
particularly American presidents sort of
a glancing blow of influence on gas
prices but it's still very popular to
assign blame to the president with the
virus situation Donald Trump miss
handling the tests has directly and
demonstrably led to more cases more
preventable death but also more panic
okay at the end of February the w-h-o
had shipped virus tests almost 60
countries the genome of the virus had
been determined virologists in berlin
germany had produced a diagnostic test
the w-h-o started shipping the tests the
united states declined to use the w-h-o
test and was counting on the CDC to
develop our own tests we don't know why
that decision was made we don't know who
made that decision someone did but the
CDC and Mike Pence who are basically in
charge as crazy as that is say that
won't say who made that decision but it
was either Trump CDC or pence or someone
working for Mike Pence who made this
call since we aren't testing people
you've got number one people who don't
know they have the virus spreading it we
don't know what areas are having more
spread people aren't taking precautions
there are more cases and thus there are
more deaths then the CDC supposedly was
ready to start testing except it was a
total failure the tests weren't
available Trump claimed travel
restrictions were in place except they
sort of weren't and they came too late
and they were focused only on China for
a while when there were other centers of
disease it took way too long for Donald
Trump to sign into law money for a virus
response and preparation the
administration was saying we are testing
people at airports when in reality they
were screening people for a fever that
was not a test for the virus it just
means you're checking for fever
that's not how you test people and of
course only a small fraction of
passengers were tested anyway when
coming in from abroad so this is not
just cartoonish political incompetence
this is a [ __ ] with a personality
disorder and possible cognitive decline
that is leading to real human costs On
February 25 Trump said everything is
under control remember this you may ask
about the corona virus which is very
well under control in our country On
February 28th Trump said this is
Democrats politicizing it to make it
seem like we have a bigger problem than
we have now the Democrats are
politicizing the corona virus you know
that corona virus
they are politicizing it we did one of
the great jobs you say how's president
Trump doing they go home and then of
course people started to die multiple
states have declared states of emergency
and even the term mishandling that's
being used doesn't really work it
assumes you are handling it but
incorrectly Trump pretended there was
nothing to handle for week after week
after week he's not miss handling it he
hasn't been handling it now let me say
one other thing I think that the refusal
to just do the testing except the w-h-o
test etc has led to more panic there's a
report in The Washington Post that the
death rate may be drastically
exaggerated early in China the death
rate was quite high that has now
averaged to this three point four
percent number that's being thrown
around the reality is that the case is
diagnosed after February one have a
significantly lower death rate the
reality is that the denominator of the
number of people who have had this is
likely extremely high I wouldn't even
rule out that maybe I had it in the
sense that last week I had a cough for a
few days and a headache and then it went
away it's conceivable that there are
people experiencing almost no symptoms
but that are in the universe of the
symptoms that are being described fever
I didn't have a fear
Koff whatever and that we don't even
know that we have it because the
denominator is so large testing would
have exposed that and it would reduce
the panic it would reduce the economic
impact it might make it so people aren't
haphazardly buying up masks and a
sanitizer that may or may not work all
of that stuff so we can't count on this
man to run a response that makes sense I
hope that there are some people around
Trump who will take it all seriously
enough and who can get things moving in
the right direction I hope other
countries are making progress there are
tests being done with combinations of
antivirals we have to see if they work
there's work being done to check whether
there's any cross immunity for people
who have had the
blew multiple vaccines are under
development there are things being done
but they take time and in the meantime
we need to be testing Trump represents
an existential threat due to his
incompetence and his narcissism and I
hate to say this but the one thing that
might get Donald Trump moving on this is
if he realizes that the more out of
control it gets the more it will hurt
his reelection chances it's sick
it's sick that that's the realization
we're counting on to get him moving but
it is very very bad weaponized is
certainly a fair term here what if you
could read ten books in just one sitting
that's exactly what one of my favorite
apps lets you do it's called blinka
stand what they do is take thousands of
popular nonfiction books they condense
them down into text or audio that you
can consume in 15 minutes
blinka snakes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blankets to get
a sample first just think how much you
can enrich yourself by being able to
soak up an entire non-fiction book in
just 15 minutes
I recently checked out the book podcast
marketing strategy by Daniel rolls and
Ciaran Rogers and so useful so
particularly applicable to what I'm
doing really recommended blink East has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different nonfiction
categories and a subscription is only
about 8 bucks a month and you get the
entire library but you can try it
totally free and get 25% off a
subscription when you go to blink is
comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video